- Welcome, everyone to
another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, I'm a
former McKinsey consultant,
and on my channel I talk
about how to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And today, let's look into
what Steve Jobs had to say
about consulting.
So of course, if Steve says
something, we all better listen.
Steve surely is a great
and intelligent man.
And I found, I think, one
of the less known videos
of Steve Jobs, where he commented
on his perspective of consulting.
The video is from a speech he gave at MIT
where he essentially shared
two points on consulting.
So, let's look at them.
I think part of what he says is correct,
but I do also think that his view
is at least partially flawed.
So, let's get into it.
- How many of you are from
manufacturing companies?
Oh, excellent.
Where are the rest of you from?
(audience laughing)
How many from consulting?
Oh, that's bad.
(audience laughing)
You should do something.
No, seriously, I don't
think there's anything
inherently evil in consulting.
I think that...
(audience laughing)
I think that, without owning something
over an extended period
of time like a few years,
where one has a chance
to take responsibility
for one's recommendations;
where one has to see one's recommendations
through all action stages,
and accumulate scar
tissue for the mistakes,
and pick oneself up off the ground
and dust oneself off,
one learns a fraction of what one can.
Coming in and making recommendations
and not owning the results,
not owning the implementation,
I think is a fraction of the value
and a fraction of the opportunity
to learn and get better.
- So, here Steve Jobs
is essentially saying
that consultants do not own
the products of their work,
and do not follow through
with it in the execution.
While I think it's fair to say
that consultants of
course own the concepts
and strategies that they might develop,
especially MBB consulting;
so McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
surely it's correct that,
at least in most cases,
you do not witness the execution
of these concepts and surely
also not responsible for them.
So, the one side of the
story is that he is correct.
And I did also witness,
sometimes even up to a point
where I thought that this
was a little bit arrogant,
that there was often a
little bit of the notion
that actually developing the
concepts and the strategies;
this is what the challenging part is.
And then the execution that
wouldn't be that tough,
that difficult.
And this is also the context
in which I released a
video a couple of weeks ago
about the Boston Consulting Group
and GameStop; legal dispute,
where Boston Consulting
Group was suing GameStop
for about $30 million in consulting fees.
So, if you haven't seen that,
I will link it somewhere above here.
But this video, this whole topic,
would also very much linked to the fact
that Boston Consulting Group
actually was not responsible,
at least from their perspective,
for the actual implementation
of the measures that they recommended,
and there seem to be lots of
disputes surrounding that.
So, this criticism that consultants
do not really own their
ideas from end to end,
from very start where
you conceptualize them
until they're financially effective,
this is of course a common criticism.
Though here, I often wonder
whether that's really
a fair point to make,
because let's look at
other roles in corporate.
Let's look at salespeople.
Do they own everything of the value chain
of what happens in their company?
No, they are just salespeople.
They're selling products.
And you could argue, this is
also only a very limited part
of what happens in a company.
What about accountants?
Financial accountants,
managerial accountants,
people working in a controlling team,
do they really own the company
processes from end to end?
Well, I'd argue they're very efficient
and capable in a certain area.
What if you are a software engineer?
So, here you certainly build something,
and are responsible for the
final product of your work,
but here also, are you
really owning it end to end?
Someone else will usually conceptualize
and define the things that
then you are supposed to build.
So, we get very detailed descriptions,
usually from the product
team telling you what to do,
and then you do just that.
Is this really end to end ownership?
Now, you could continue
talking about engineers
working in R&D or people
working in production.
I'd say that in almost every role
in a corporate environment,
you are only responsible
for certain part of the
whole, but not everything.
And in this same way,
the strategy consultants
are responsible for developing
this strategy concepts,
and of course, many other things
depending on the types of
projects they're working on,
and they're just not that different
from many of these other roles as well.
- And so, you do get a
broad cut at companies,
but it's very thin.
It's like a picture of a...
I'm a vegetarian, so I won't use steak,
but it's like a picture of a banana.
(audience laughing)
You might get a very accurate picture,
but it's only two dimensional.
And without the experience
of actually doing it,
you never get three dimensional.
So, you might have a lot
of pictures on your walls,
you can show it off to your friends,
You can say, "Look,
I've worked in bananas,
I've worked in peaches,
I've worked in grapes."
but you never really taste it.
And I think that...
that's what I think.
(audience clapping)
- So, this point builds on the notion
that consultants don't really understand
what they're talking about;
they're the best there for
very superficial knowledge
of the things that they
express their opinions on.
And here again, in favor of Steve Jobs,
of course, as a consultant
you will rarely have the
knowledge that someone has
who is really working
in an operational way
on a certain topic for
years and years and years.
Of course such a person will
likely be more knowledgeable,
at least on some parts of the
things than you as consultant.
And in addition to that,
I do think it's true
also from my personal experience,
that sometimes that's the problem;
that as a consultant, you need
to be perceived as competent,
and you need to do things
to, to some extent,
fake this competency, even
though you're still learning,
you're still in the process of acquiring
all the knowledge that
you need to acquire.
There was a Harvard
business reviewer article
a couple of years ago
that called this the "learning
credibility tension".
That's a tension that many people
in professional services face.
So, it's not only specific to consultant,
but a very relevant,
interesting topic indeed.
I created a video about
that a couple of months ago,
I will also link it above here,
with some very interesting
insights on that.
Check it out if this topic interests you.
But that being said, I
still think that this notion
that consultants don't really know
what they're talking about, in the end,
is still very much flawed as well.
From my perspective,
it's actually one of
the biggest advantages
of having worked several years
in consulting, that after this time,
you will be able to have
a meaningful conversation
with any senior leader of most companies
independent from the
industry or from the function
that the leader is working in,
just based on your insights
and based on your contextual understanding
of what the key topics are that matter
to these type of people,
and of course also what they mean
on an executional operational level.
Because in the end of the day,
these are things that you will
at least have some exposure
on in your work as a consultant this way.
On top of that, the big
variety of different topics
you will work on, at
least in MBB consulting,
really enables you to, if
then you need to go deep
in a certain part of your career
also after consulting, to
give you the confidence
that you can understand
also complex things
in a short amount of time,
and give you the ability to really master
lots of knowledge in short time,
to get this done, and to
make yourself knowledgeable
whenever this is then needed.
So, in the end of the day,
to me, this comes back
to the old debate, whether
being a generalist is better,
or whether being a specialist is better.
And in my humble opinion,
there are very good arguments to be made
that, especially in the
beginning of your career,
it makes a lot of sense to
become a generalist first.
You will still have
plenty of opportunities
later down in your career
to amass niche knowledge,
to amass knowledge in
a very specific domain,
to become this very T-shaped profile.
Whereas on the one hand side,
very broad general
understanding of things,
and then also is able to go deep
and has the main expertise
in some specific areas.
That often makes a lot of sense,
because if you specialize yourself
too early on in your career,
but understand that the rewards
for that can be significant as well,
then often it is difficult.
Then after years and years and
years in this specific role,
you then want to do things
which are very very different from that.
But I'm very interested to
hear your opinion as well.
Do you actually agree with
what Steve Jobs said or not?
Just leave a comment below
in the comment section.
Very happy to have a
conversation with you.
And as always, if you took any
value from this video at all,
destroy the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to stay up to date.
My name is Heinrich.
Big, big, thanks to the members
of the channel for support.
I release videos every single Saturday.
See you again next week.
Until then, all the best
to you, and bye bye.